what the [__] are we doing here that's
deep bro hello welcome to that's deep
bro i'm your host christina pazsitzky
thank you for downloading this episode
I'm so excited for you to hear this
conversation that I recorded with the
wonderful talented hilarious Kevin
Christie you know I I don't have an easy
schedule these days and we cancelled and
rebook like 500 times and kevin was kind
enough to be patient with me and he came
in and we just had the most mind-blowing
discussion about well it started it
started about grief because he lost his
father a few years ago I lost my mother
one year ago and I had him in the studio
and we did an episode about grief
because it was fresh for me but he had
you know had a few years under his belt
and it's kind of interesting where the
conversation went because you'd think
like hey Christina thanks for the
ultimate bummer of a discussion thanks
thanks for bringing me down on a Tuesday
but no it was actually really positive
kind of weird so before we get into that
I just want to have I would make you
aware of some announcements October 23rd
I'm an Indianapolis at Morty's comedy
club October 24th Cincinnati go bananas
and then washington d.c december 9th and
10th at the DC improv come see me come
see me tell jokes these shows have been
so fun and so amazed and this is the new
model for me i think i'm just going to
do one night two nights max in the city
that way I enjoy it and I get to meet
you guys after and we talked and we cry
and it's [__] rat so they're okay and
who else what else do we have oh yeah
all right guys this episode of that's d
pro is sponsored in part by talk space
hello I absolutely love talk space I'm a
huge advocate of therapy I think every
single episode therapy comes up because
it's that important I think that
everybody should be talking to somebody
who is qualified to walk you through
this life because look do you have all
the answers I certainly don't and it's
helped me tremendously to seek the help
of a therapist and I actually have
started using talk space as well I
download it you there's an app you can
put on your iPhone and you can talk to
somebody whenever you want therapy can
and should be affordable confidential
and convenient and this is exactly what
talk space is only with talk spaced you
get unlimited messaging to your
dedicated licensed therapist for just
thirty two dollars a week that is a
bargain 32 bucks you got to be kidding
me join over 300,000 users who already
know that with talk space you can text
audio message or video message or
therapist as many times as you want
without having to wait a week for your
next appointment because what talk space
your therapist is always in your pocket
or on your computer that's what I like
about talk space is if you're having a
mini meltdown you can just text a sigh
person you know and they get back to you
immediately it's amazing it's amazing
and now you can even schedule a live
video session with your therapist right
from your smartphone help show support
for this show by visiting talk space.com
slash bro for a special thirty dollar
discount off your first month or
download the talk space app on the Apple
or Android app store and use coupon code
bro BR 0 bros talk space therapy for how
we live today no kid and thank you talk
space for being an ongoing an ongoing
sponsor of your mom's house I just
absolutely love it and I know many of
you have already emailed me tweeted me
letting me know that you use talk space
so thank you also this episode is
brought to you by loom and leaf bloom
and leaf LOM and leaf le AF com which is
the new memory foam luxury mattress
brought to you by satva mattress company
sa a TV a mattress company as you know
Tom my husband and I have been that's
kind of like three people that was just
Tom comma my husband and I we sleep on a
sofa bed every single night and we found
this company by a fortuitous happy
accident and we ordered a mattress
online and at first you think this is
terrifying how do I know I'm going to
love this how do I know what this is but
trust me the quality is better I would
say then the stuff you get in stores if
not comparable the only difference is
they don't have the overhead of retail
space so they pass the savings on to you
the consumer everything is made in
America which is great their customer
service is truly truly fantastic i'm on
their site right now lumen leaf com and
i've been on here not longer than 30
seconds and what does that call the pops
up a little instant messenger thing how
can i help you welcome to lumen leaf and
someone's there all the time to walk you
through this so i understand might feel
weird don't feel weird because someone's
there to help plant-based memory foam
that's the new mattress of lumen leaf
memory foam is amazed i can't wait to
get my memory foam bed there's cooling
gel and breathable channels so you feel
cool all the time you know you're not
sweating it up in the bed there's a 75
day in home trial that means you can
sleep on this mattress for 75 days if
you don't like it they'll take it back
but I don't think you're not going to
like it nationwide delivery and in-home
setup that means they set the bed up for
you take away your old mattress for a
small fee it's really really great you
know some other companies they just
throw a mattress on your doorstep and
you're like great what no they set it up
it's one
full check it out I'm looking at one bed
here for nine hundred ninety nine
dollars oh let's see the mattress and i
click on it right now this is the lumen
leaf oh yeah there's layers of stuff oh
yeah look at this come on can't be beat
alright check it out guys lumen leaf com
Thank You satva for a sponsoring that's
deep bro I appreciate it alright guys so
let's get into it with Kevin Christie as
I said before he was here about a year
ago i really wish i had written down the
episode in fact i'm going to go right
now into my back history let's see what
episode he was in so you guys because I
know I know I know I get it you're gonna
hear and I'd be like what one is a
Christina we can piece it was Kevin it I
thought you loved the internet okay hold
on hold on Kevin Christy that's deep bro
let's see I think it was episode 48 nope
episode 42 is the first time kevin was
in here episode 42 so if you want to
listen to that before you listen to this
one i think it's an interesting
juxtaposition because i think both of us
were pretty bummed out the last time we
spoke I was pregnant my mom had died was
very confused I kevin was living alone
and bummed out and you know it was a
pretty heavy episode but things have
changed he's a lot happier and I'm a lot
happier so time is a wonderful healer
and I think you'll be really really
interested to see what lessons we have
learned from grief all right let's get
into it I think I want to play the
sisters of mercy right because it's
still December bros and I like to get
deep on it oh let's play okay but some
of their intros are just too long okay
where the [__] oh here we go let's play
I love this one alright guys let's get
off and then let's get happy bye
you
where's your
bring it up to me like you know you do
this thing imma get I know I do this
thing and that's when you think you've
been clever yeah but has anyone
acknowledged how clever you are I don't
know it does it's irrelevant it's just
that you they knows like sometimes you
do this thing after work I had the lily
I hosted a thing and she was like we had
to cut out like a thousand of them like
a thousand of them like just the guy
would just as soon as you would be done
talking and you just cut your mic cuz
you go so I we're rolling now okay Kevin
don't use the N word so much oh sorry
hey thank you so much for coming back to
that steep place you've been you are
absolutely one of my favorite human
beings and by far one of the most
popular guests really messy bro yeah
you're a fantastic podcaster fantastic
human being thank you and thank you for
bearing with me we've rescheduled this
about 5,000 times so yeah you're the
best dude no where else does no problem
it's the room yeah I I don't listen to
myself on your mom's house cuz I we
upgraded our mic so these are fancy as
[__] yeah they're real they look really
they are this is like Howard Stern gray
yeah they are and I had this habit of
like my nose would always run oh we're
taping and I could hear myself like
dropping the whole yeah yeah I got to
turn myself that's you this is me okay
so I did consciously not yeah I have to
hold my breath now yeah when I talk like
when I'm working I'll like sail line at
the very end like I just hold in so I
never move Oh what you're at your acting
job yeah and whatever acting job I'm go
whatever I'm doing I I now have to like
say line just play like like flex my
base so that I don't go how long have
you had this tick I mean my stepsister
pointed it out when I was 11 that's so
far back as long as I thought I was
rural area as long as I basically was an
annoying [__]
oh my god it's terrible it's terrible
yeah it's embarrassing so you are on
masters of sex which is one of my
absolute favorite shows that's cool and
I'm only like two episodes deep into
this season right but I'm eagerly
anticipating the return of my sweet
Lester sweet sweet Lester he is the most
the sweetest characters a sweet
defenseless little thing yeah he's the
most innocent person in the whole cast
yeah character yeah he's like he's the
innocent he's basically like like a dog
that just gets kicked around the lobby
right who's super talented and and from
those filming no one cares no one cares
masters of sex is screech yeah okay yeah
yeah yeah we are so lovable and I always
I'm so excited when I see you on that
show and I mean I'm excited when I see I
mean I tried eggs I mean you know like
coming from The Comedy Store which is
basically the gutter okay is it anymore
but like when we were first there it was
the actual gutter so to be on anything
even remotely respectable it feels like
it feels like I'm part of like a special
government program right don't you feel
like you're getting one over enjoy
business when somebody is like when
someone's like you're so successful like
what we're talking about who me no I'm
not I just got a call from Tommy told me
I got a nine o'clock Wednesday yeah it's
just it's yeah it feels like I trip if I
feel like I'm tricking everyone front I
feel like a fraud all the time yeah yeah
yeah I do you think there's ever a point
where we will stop feeling like fry hope
not cuz then that means I'm like too
used to it all right you've lost your
perspective mmm that's the nice thing is
that stupid tick reminds me that I suck
at the end of every sentence like
there's never a moment or I'm like
you're killing it cuz then that awful
noise your minds like actually you're a
[__] yeah do you think that's what that
is that you're you're unconsciously
invalidating what you've said no I think
it's my it's like a it's me thinking
what something I said it's funny okay
but knowing to not laugh at your own
joke
I see yeah I get I guess oh yeah okay so
you're giving yourself a prop without
being yeah it's like it's like you know
when you said you know you're saying
something relatively funny yeah but you
don't want to be the guy who's laughing
as it comes out of his mouth right that
sucks it's so bad that's the worse than
you're like you're like a weird that's
like a dad joke move that hey yeah so
you just like hold it like you just so
that that is is my what I thought was my
[__] unconscious quiet acknowledgment
that maybe i said something funny but no
now knowing that everyone hears it all
the time Wow and so so you do modify it
now look you're acting I try you tried
to know I don't think I control it all
the time like I definitely hear it they
don't get when they don't catch it yeah
yeah and i offered you lacroix when you
came in and what did you say I said no
they suck I hate him um are you even
American was so you talk if you said you
talked by this on your podcast which is
well Nick we do recommendation episodes
really like recommend three things we
like and Nick found some new seltzer
water that he really likes oh and I was
like good cuz Lacroix sucks Wow cuz
again it smells like it's gonna taste
really yummy and then it's just dry
bubble water right but here's the thing
is that as it tricks you into thinking
you're drinking soda so you're like oh
I'm not drinking just sparkling water
I'm drinking a soda without the sugar
cuz I'm 40 and I can't have soda yeah I
know and feeling green tea yeah I hate
all of it I hate green tea and I'm a
trainer ste are trying to give up sugar
as well as much like yeah it's important
every thing it's very hard but like I
said look at Dean Del Rey he's lost like
30 pounds he looks great I don't think
he's gonna be diabetic anymore I think
he fixed it is he had the kind word that
you give yourself is that right he was
on the road to the beetus and ya know he
had it like he went the doctor and
augurs like will you have diabetes seems
like what that's a good impression yeah
and he let I think like one is the hard
one type twos the less hard one no no
well there's one you give yourself from
having a shitty diet and there's one you
like there's one you're right that's
you're born with I think he's reversed
in man
good for him so I'd say the name of your
podcast so occasionally awesome and
that's what nikki is with Nick Youssef
ok and that's on all things comedy to do
right okay so guys check out this their
show as well Wow ok so so there's that
you hate Lacroix wow wow make your funny
sound wow wow so I wanted to have you
back because as long as we're on the
light topic of grief let's talk about it
well who better to just you know what I
found on on that see bro is that we
Canadians are actually the most equipped
people to discuss absurd profane tragedy
like we are the ones who should be
talking about death and miscarriages air
addiction and all because most of us
have experienced it a and B like we've
processed it enough to get to the humor
side of it hopefully yeah I don't know
if I I'm almost there with my mom and
being able to joke about it it's been a
year it's been a year for me and so this
has been almost a year since we recorded
our grief episodes I wanted to have you
back and check in and see what's changed
hasn't gotten better I almost think it's
it may have regressed really well I had
a death my friend of mine died what like
six about almost six months ago oh my
god and he was like the best dude no
yeah it was the best duty was only 46 it
was cancer granny with yeah exactly cuz
limit literally like a ray of light
human like the best person ever and so I
want to think it's maybe regressed a
little because of that because of that
and on it maybe a little too because I
live with someone now and trying to
maybe be like a grown man and like a
dull to like is there for someone else
maybe Earl as much as I can be as may be
made me check in with that stuff a
little less chicken with that stuff like
the grief like the kind the feelings and
the like
uh how to deal with it and make sure I'm
dealing with it and that stuff wears
like I've con I think because I'm almost
40 and I think maybe I'm getting into
the area of my life was just like just
be a man in stock like stop talking and
I said to my friend yeah I just a
Whitney I was like I'm so sick of
discussing my personality right it's
lame boring right past a certain age
it's like a masturbatory it's
masturbatory because a everyone so
similar right so you're kind of like i'm
wearing jeans this was like no but i'm
warren g stupid like these are jeans
it's like we're all wearing jeans guys
but it's not and part of me is like i
should be dealing with this on my own
necessarily so sharing it mate so maybe
I'm not sharing it quite as much as I
should be as you should be meaning you
want if I'm having trouble with it maybe
I don't like like vocalize it to the
house yeah part of my girl person ok and
you're doing that because maybe I'm just
cuz I I don't wanna I don't want to like
share a bummer with with someone oh you
don't want to be like hey I'm thinking
about my dad today and that's tough yeah
to her but she sense that you're off
yeah and a night and I try to tell her
like if I'm upset at you i promise i
will tell you yeah cuz i think she seems
like you're mad at me right i'm
definitely not she never does anything
wrong that's actually borderline
annoying right super nice holistic way
Danny after just tell me later the
thoughtful young lady what is a comedian
no choice an interior designer oh great
yeah got even better your house yeah my
house looks great and she's nice to me
it's it's a hard to deal with and now
but that is now that is something
someone's being really nice to you it
sounds like and which I have always had
a lot of trouble which I know last time
barrier we talked about it a little i
believe it's the guilt like she can cook
which I've never experienced in a
relationship and it's uh the guilt I
feel just for eating a meal someone made
for me hahahahaha I i'm just like i like
i don't know how to like express the
egg-wich like that was really not like i
like it was so nice of you
she ate it too but I'm just like cuz I
don't know how to cook at all it seems
hard there's like heat involved like
there's so much [__] involved right it's
such a thoughtful thing to do it is
isn't it especially when it's like a
well thought-out meal that's good for
you and also taste good was like like on
the way here I was hungry I I just hate
i bought some like weird cookies at the
gas station and some wasabi peas in this
[__] green team because I'm an it
because I got my full idiot who doesn't
know any I just respond to my urges all
the time right with no thought no
forethought no forethought oh I'm close
to forty i should plan out my meal maybe
have an apple in the car or something
like is something relatively good for
you sure I'm like now there's a there's
a Unocal 76 is depend like all that's 72
76 station take care of me but there is
something I mean there's a level of
intimacy where you have to allow someone
to care for you yeah and that's kind of
hard to very hard for me to let meet you
I don't ask for help that's always been
something I've worked on yeah I don't
ask for help and I don't tell people
when I need stuff that's been my bandit
but that ends up screwing me that's my
same exact problem yeah yeah maybe we
had parents who my parents were kind of
hands off yeah there was a kind of a
notion that uh that's a nice way of
saying they sucked they didn't suck they
were like you know what they were they
were awkward were they English no but
they come from that they could come from
English people they're awkward yeah well
then there you go they don't they were
like they're sweet people but they
didn't there they're like they're like
me all right there awkward and didn't
want to like they were I think more
afraid of screwing up then they were
brave enough to just like do it did you
to do it and fail yeah and so also but
there also was I think a notion that
like Oh Kevin's fine yeah Kevin de he's
fine he's over there doing it see I
think that's why I feel a level of
comfortability with comics because we're
all so afraid of intimacy of real ex we
can get deep on [__] like we'll talk
about our childhood feelings
but actual intimacy it's that's another
level like I don't I can't do that i can
only deal with my husband and my child
and maybe my dogs yeah I I have trouble
with it I think from also a male
perspective in that there is a certain
level of stability and like assuredness
I think the other person wants to have
in me they don't like I don't think
anyone wants to look at the person
they're living with who they have a life
with and have them be like I'm terrified
I don't know what's gonna happen I don't
know if I'm gonna be okay and I have no
idea what to do right now like that's
just like a ho I'm like oh oh oh I see
like that's that to me is like a little
that kind of vulnerability as a male as
a male yes dude right you don't want the
woman to see your we're suppose it well
also stabilities a lot of what in my
experience women find attractive about
me well and I'll tell you that's what I
love about my husband because I came
from such chaos that Tom's normalcy is
the most attractive people are like so
quiet so boy I mean segura everyone was
like I guys like 40 when he was 23 cuz
ya so responsible and quiet and to me
that was like exciting somebody who just
yeah just [__] normal yeah and I
didn't have tons of chaos around me but
I'm just yeah you'd raised by people
that were muted yeah we just for a quiet
yeah group of people and that felt
comfortable yeah so okay but here's the
thing too is that Tom will be vulnerable
sometimes like when he's sick and that
does kind of rattle me I'll be like oh
god like it's on an unconscious child II
level yeah but I get that but but just
know that your woman also can take care
of you too like that's probably I'm on
set when we first started dating we've
been together only two months I got skin
cancer which didn't tell anyway this
crazy but it wasn't like the gnarly kind
it was just I had to like take a giant
hole out of my head yeah it look like a
shot with a bullet right here in my god
but she had to kind I had to kind of let
her take care of me yeah for a little
while cuz like my face blew up and it
was like I literally
stupid like because the I had to get
plastic surgery except ago I was working
on masters of sex and so they gave me an
episode off to like uh get the surgery
but when they were done like the guy had
to like pull my scalp down so this
eyebrow was raised like I was real sassy
look too guilty you had to write your
character all these sassy lon yeah well
luckily our glasses sook I didn't notice
it but I'm ever I went in to like show
the makeup are she was like all right
we'll just all right like but my so my
girlfriend really did have to like take
care of me to certain degree especially
and a lot cans for being together like
three months right like this was like we
hadn't been together that long oh wow so
you know I was kind of like laid up with
this like weird black eye all over my
face and like bandages on my face like
an old dude like it was not super sexy
right and I had to kind of relented I
didn't know how to take painkillers for
the first day I didn't take enough and
it hurts so bad I was like I can't sleep
and she had to be like well I'll call my
french used to be like super into pain
pills shows us what to do drug addicts
are so useful when you don't know what
to do so what what did you have you just
have to keep taking them can I didn't
say goodnight okay I didn't know how
many to take I didn't take enough I was
just smelling the keys the cupid it all
the time right yeah I guess a baseline
like I don't know everyone so so you're
saying like so you have these days where
because I to I have my my days where I'm
I had this crazy day when I went to go
get a massage on the anniversary of my
mother's death I like checked myself
into a spa right cuz I was like this is
this is a bad day for me I just have to
be I have to be not around people yeah I
can't do this so I checked myself into
the spa for the day and I'm in the
waiting room and my mother's name was
Edith and there's I've met maybe one
Edith there's six in the entire country
right and I'm sitting there and a rocker
yeah right there's nobody named Edith
and the woman comes in and introduced
the masseuse to her client hi my name is
Edith and she said and I was like you
got to be [__] me like of all the
places and it was this like you know
it's a cosmic joke right I go this place
to get away from it and that's the one
[__] name I here and he
Williams yeah do you think that's like I
eat the universe feel that like that was
like if you were a spurt do you think so
that's God's pinky going hey there I I
did think that day that was like my mom
given awake because I'll so crazy right
before my friend Brett passed away I
went to New York because my friend was
like my other friend was like you should
probably come see him cuz it was like
he's not going to be it's gettin it's
gettin close you know so I went see him
and we hung out for a few days and the
in his the hospital he was in and the
way I met him was I went to high school
with this band called Eve 6 oh yeah yeah
and that's i met brett he was their art
director and i met brett on the like set
of one other videos i was like you're an
art director i'm gonna go to art school
can you look at my like art like my
portfolio and that's how he became
friends and that's how we like work
together over the years but so I'm I go
to see him it's very hard but like you
know beautiful and very profound feeling
and real and his level of bravery was
shocking and everything and then I'm you
know the day I fly out I go to the
hospital early to hang out just with him
and it was like it's gonna it at that
point was like maybe it's going to be a
couple months I was like I'm gonna come
back in a month and he's like I'm like I
gotta go and he's like all right I'm let
me try to stand up so I can hug you
because he was you know if cancer just
takes everything everything he was like
a skeleton and I hug him and I'm like
you know if you need anything just call
gamma plane and then I go to the airport
and it's and I'm waiting in line and
then Eve sixes hit inside-out comes on
and I'm like you [__] and then
I have to just kind of get out of line
for a second yeah and just be like
mm-hmm just like [__] it there it I
don't know I in a weird way I oddly feel
bad for people that don't experience
death young enough right right as i was
telling i was saying this to I think my
girlfriend that like cuz recently a
professional skateboarder passed away
yesterday oh yeah this guy dylan Rieder
yeah who was a 28 get leukemia oh god
but me and my girlfriend my girlfriend
has didn't we weren't friends with him
but she had hung out with him a few
times and with her one of her friends
years ago and I've always been we're
aware of him through skateboarding he's
a really good skateboarder and so we
went to a restaurant a few months ago
and someone walks in who looked like a
skeleton and I saw this person and it
triggered me I was like that looks just
like Brett right beforehand and my
girlfriend gets like really kind of she
goes kind of like like like like ice
cold and then she goes outside but she's
like I gotta go outside for a second I
walk outside Michael what's the matter
she goes oh my god is that dylan Rieder
hmm and I didn't recognize him and I
know what he looks like cuz he's one of
the best looking people or just boy of
all time he's one of the best looking
man anyone's ever seen yeah and what's
so credible about him is with those
looks he could have just been a famous
model or an actor but he was so good at
skateboarding and to get that good
escape when you pay that debt in blood
yeah like right getting wrecked and just
being in a van with the grossest people
have right it's like being it's the
athletic equivalent of like doing the
open mic of the store for ten years yeah
yeah and he Pat so he passes away
yesterday and our day before yesterday
and again I didn't know him but it's
just it you feel once you've lost some
people yeah your empathy kind of goes up
yeah and it just me and my girl were
just genuinely sad even though she'd
only met him a few times I'd never even
really met him just cuz I know what his
friends are going through right now oh
yeah and it's just this it's so hard but
it does give you my perspective on the
world's better I have a better
perspective at least on the outside
world my perspective towards myself is a
little focaccia garbage yeah yep but
like I don't sweat things in life that
don't matter yeah anymore I got it I'm
just like that's [__] yeah my
[__] meter is relatively precise
yeah I'm like that's some [__] over
there then I'll get flavor that I tell
you what changed me to death yes because
you also realize you don't have the time
you think you do not really
you got a fraction of what yeah so I
tell people on this show if you're like
in your 20s and you're listening to this
and you're like I want to try being an
artist I want to be a filming I want to
do something but I live in a shitty town
I live with my parents [__] it go do it
dude cuz you don't have very long and
the sooner you start the band it is
there's an amazing thing to like you can
just kind of figure stuff out you and
you do jazz a will to start is actually
a little more difficult than the
figuring out of things the fear of
starting yeah the fear of starting
that's what I was thinking about it on
the way here i will say that grief might
the my father dying in the way he died
died has made me more risk averse
interesting because i have no sense that
there's anyone I don't feel us that I
have like actual safety net of any kind
right so i think it's made me a more
cautious as a human just about things
like taking risks in life like physical
know all kinds really yeah i just like
artistically career wise i just have a
sense of like let's just stick to what
we know we're good at and like because i
don't have a sense that if the [__] hits
the fan dolby any like real people for
me to go to which is essentially false
it's wrong yeah but in my head it makes
sense see i had the opposite effect when
my mother died i actually thought that
the doors had flung open for me
creatively and I think as part of that
is her negative voice her German of me
was up there it was in my head it was
internalized and she was crate like
schizophrenic and listening to my shows
and writing things down so it wasn't
just me being paranoid she really was
watching and listening and critiquing
from that point but I'd actually opened
me up and having a child really makes
you go whoa I better start taking care
of myself because this existence is very
finite and people really need me that
little person depends on me being alive
yeah I mean I think I think now that I'm
in a relationship with someone and it's
like serious and we live together and
it's stable
I do have a sense of like right call it
because the doctors did it right also
liked people I know keep getting [__]
diseases oh my god oh my god so it's
like go to look like I'm you know I was
texting your friends like to go doctor I
will make it i made a dr packed with my
friend was like dr. packed yeah yeah
let's go get the one where they do the
things to report like who cares haha
that's what I'm so afraid of now that I
turned 40 is that they're gonna put
their fingers in mice but I just blasted
a baby out of there you don't have a
prostate gland what are you worried
about no they but they finger your
butthole Oh as a for you're a woman you
start that and they smash your titties
and mammograms and it's [__] I'm er uh
but also what's a relief i'm having a
kid is that you stop doing the me me me
thing that you discussed earlier yeah
what am I me me my person my my neuroses
and then there's an age where like you
have to start caring about other people
outside of you so I realized and I'm not
even just a child I could be your loved
one yes your dogs other people's kids
[__] somebody but me also I feel like
passes I don't know if women feel this
way but I feel like past 35 as a dude
your job is to just be useful right it's
not like it's not your body or your
looks like yeah it's you your job is to
be effective that's interest I never
heard that just bit like that's my
function in the world effective for
other people or for whatever that
whatever the thing is like I don't walk
on a set if I'm working and and get to
be like the the kind of mercurial
temperamental actor that it's like
that's not I'm too old for that [__]
don't they were like what the hell
what's your [__] problem oh yeah I've
been doing it like almost 20 years like
I I'm like a plumber I show up and I'm
like I turn the pipes and then I'm back
in the car right like it's that's endo
and and because I noticed that it has a
certain age the all the other actors i
worked with that are like older than me
like 40 s or above that's what they were
like yeah they'd see some actor like
they just roll their eyes at the kid in
their 20s being like but i'm not sure
they're like I just get it done we're
gonna we're a meal penalty leather [__]
let's go this is Union time here like
we're not we're not making dragons
Shakespeare let's get that stop shop I
just see it like it's it's your job is
to just be useful to others here because
by now I'll you should you should kind
of know what you're trying by 40 I one
hopes that you would have it at least in
one area yeah yeah yeah not everything
will be figured out always but at least
what your drive is what your yeah the
thing that I means you when you're on
like younger comics and you hear the sum
of the like confusion they have towards
comedy you're like I really have that
same confusion yeah well that's cuz we
figured it out we've gone through the
whole or you just know it's there's 12
different kinds of audiences I it's not
you know you can kind of but what
they're like and then like oh then I
didn't realize you're like yeah no I
felt that same way but like if you feel
that same way all the time you're like
the hell's wrong with you man yeah good
together get it together and if it's not
working move on because there are people
who for in comedy they never progress
past a certain point I think there's a
handful of those dude and you're like
bro you got it you got to go into
somewhere else this isn't for you this
is literally it doesn't you're not cute
anymore right so you can't get there's a
lot of stuff you could that is funny
because you're kind of young and cute
and and the notion of feeling that way
is interesting in that like age range
yeah but past certain ages like wait
what you seem kind of confused yeah why
are you why are you the 50 year old guy
with the leather cuff yes and like that
the cool shirt like you're not cool bro
you're [__] you're an old person yeah
you know you're knowledgeable right like
being you should not care about being
cool anymore right I was at a commercial
audition once and this great this guy
must have been like 60 and I don't know
why he said this or the context he goes
goes when you get old you're not cute
you wear round shoes and loose pants and
I like yet no one wants to see a dude in
tight pants best asserted that just
looks like a guy got a new wife and she
took him shopping and she's super young
yeah yeah yes exactly yeah yeah and
there's nothing wrong with um living the
era that you're in like I you know we
see it in our business I don't know why
people lie about their age it always
made me bananas like you can Wikipedia
somebody and find out exactly how old
they are like my age is on my Emily be
yes it's not it's stupid I save my edge
in a bit now it feels like border is
like liberating right some do you I'm
this age yeah it's there's no shame in
it and you're not calling anybody I mean
most of us look our [__] names yeah
and it from then on you know why I feel
certain ways yeah I'm like a [__] about
it yeah and that's that's a good thing
about getting older as you give a [__]
about less and less and you care about
the important stuff yeah it gets real
narrow for me it's real [__] easy and
narrow it's Ellis Tom dogs home yeah you
know and then all the other [__] crap
yeah of whatever I didn't do the order
might be Tom Ellis Ellis and Tom are
tied and then also you see home people
do the same thing that's what's
interesting now is that I'm old enough
when I'm like oh I know you're doing
over there yeah see someone you like all
you're doing that thing I know where
that's gonna go yeah yeah that I'm go
there then you'll do this yeah whatever
you wear this shirt for a while I go you
were in that shirt okay right yeah it's
fine yeah it's so funny and then also to
like use I celebrate successes of others
of myself but you also kind of go like
okay that's going to come and that's
gonna go and that's going to come and
that's gonna go in it yeah it all goes
and likes everything moves in cycles and
seasons so I don't get as upset anymore
about things that I used to time is
super fake like past a certain 8 a-8
starts to just go faster for some reason
yeah and so I don't I don't like have
benchmarks if someone has like when I
see yourself before you got your
butthole mouth I can well this is crap
like if I give but home I did you have
that more like i don't i don't if i have
made a list of things i wanted to be by
40 I don't know if my life right now
would be better than that or worse no
I'm super glad I would didn't make a
list well you know what's interesting I
just met met up with people that I
hadn't seen since I was about 20 years
old recently and
in Seattle what is it and we all ended
up rat like it was it was great because
it was we none of us have miserable jobs
everyone ended up great and I'm like
that's good but I didn't I always had an
idea of who I wanted to be at 40 I don't
have it exact like I will have 2.5
children in a home and raided but I had
a vague idea that I would be creative
that I would have a good marriage that I
would be you know a lover of dogs like
it it wasn't it wasn't down to the moon
because you can't plan is what I'm
saying because as we learned with life
and death and birth and you control none
of this even with birthing they're like
what's your plan your birth plan I'm
like yeah you got to be [__] me
right like I'm gonna try not to die hard
as I can right there's no plan the plan
is God in that baby and you are the
vessel of this existence but it's going
to tear through you or it's going to get
cut out again or whatever but you have
no control that's it my girls younger
than me and everyone specialized just
like what are you like like do you do it
like for like your new future what do
you plan Isles and I bore I like giggle
I'm like a plan is just maybe a funny
little thing I wrote down but I didn't
plan for life I have now I just write
ooh respond the best I can as time goes
on but you're also listening I think to
your inner voice that goes yes no like I
like this I don't like that the one
thing I've done OK at is like I didn't
say no to things out of fear that I'm
like when I first started I didn't have
a lot of intention to be an actor but
some was like do you want to try this I
was like okay cuz I did it to me at the
time I was like well if it goes bad I
was do good [__] night and my mom
time ever my mom asking me like I don't
know how you go and do auditions like
aren't you embarrassed and I'm like yeah
I'm incredibly embarrassed but i figure
i'll never see any of them ever again
yeah and for the most part i'm right now
granted I started to get better so I
wasn't ever see myself right right but
it just was like I don't know I I didn't
I had a guess an ok perspective on it
well you had no strong attachment to
your success or your failure like I
think because you went into a
thing with okay yeah i'll give that a
try versus I'm fun I have to die have to
succeed if I don't succeed I will
[__] loser and if I'm a loser i will
be homeless and i will die and the
stakes weren't that i never think in
terms of success actually read and never
knew how to put into words that but it
was you guys I'm saying I'm Isaiah I'm
say some [__] I did Eve on this I love
when dogs make decisions it's the bet I
love when a dog is sitting somewhere and
it just goes like it goes I'm go sit
over there and then it goes and see so
they're like yeah I decide to come over
here and she'll bark for nothing nothing
happened right now that prompted that uh
you know but I was reading a thing and
it was like I get tricked by clickbait
all time I was like ten secrets John
Malkovich says for his productivity I
was like [__] am I look at that but you
have to click like thirty thousand
arrows I hate that up roxas problem or
answers.com or whatever the [__] it is
no but he goes I'm driven not ambitious
oh and he was like my drive is to do it
well past that I don't give a [__] and I
was like oh [__] that's how I am I'd
never heard someone describe it like
that clearly to me I've always just
wanted to do stood job yes like I want
to go in even when I don't like
sometimes I'll go on an audition I don't
want but I don't want to tell my agents
I don't want I want to have the argument
so I'll just go and I figure like I'll
just go and I won't get it but what the
problem is once I get in the room I have
to do a good job I don't want to like
embarrass myself of course so I like I
need that's what I care about like I
need to either make the painting look
like a certain way or make a joke as
funny as i want to be i just adore make
the crowd laughs certain amount like I
just want to do a good job and pass that
I don't really think about it all you
don't want to think about the outcome
well all of that to me is a out of my
control yeah a lot of that shit's kind
of feels fake it's not stuff that lasts
or you can depend on new whereas like if
you learn how to do something right then
you can do it right again you do it over
and over and the fruits of your labor
come or they don't come yet success it's
it's like it's like hoping everyone
doesn't die yeah it's like saying you're
like you know if we
all the stuff everything will be greats
like yeah but at the same time all your
friends are gonna die yeah half of them
earlier than you're planning half you
think I don't know dear guy Kevin no I
mean everyone's gonna die before you're
ready yeah you're never ready that's
true there's no ready for that that's
what I that's why I feel sad anytime
anyone does it's because I know many of
the people around them weren't ready
yeah and that's so [__] yeah that and
it an addiction on the last episode I
talked about characteristics adult
children of alcoholics have and what the
interesting thing was with people that
are addicted to things it is like living
with a zombie it's it is like that
person's a ghost their shell already
yeah you're just waiting for the
physical death because they've already
checked out on you and your family yeah
and the thing is the addict [__]
everyone else around them it's not them
they're [__] even though they are
[__] that it's you and everyone else
that loves that person yeah they're
drowning I mean when I go to al-anon
meetings those give me tremendous
perspective because I hear [__] in those
rooms where I'm like holy God your
parents are so [__] like well it's
like there's it's like they're trying to
make you go mentally insane it's like
they will come for like let's make
someone bipolar like it's like that was
their goal and you're just like holy God
it's like all my parents were like a
skosh distant like right it really like
right it put it puts the needle back at
zero for me and I go home and I'm like
let's do the dishes like you know like
char let's let's be of service here
because this is not so bad look let's
make someone bipolar it's so gia like
they're so there are some people out
there that had kids hide that it's like
they had kids as part of a like
dastardly yeah like goal to ruin someone
rain like let's hit like it like that
movie uh like in the company of men were
like what's ruined life right like why
did you choose to procreate not you
hated each other yeah hated your lives
yeah and you despite those bad judgments
you were like let's go forward with
their Charlie hey I'm a total garbage
fire and like I want to make someone cry
too
yours bill net that I want to make
someone cry for no reason in their 30s
comply for know like I don't know where
I just want to sabotage any sense of
self-esteem is ever gonna I want them to
be so triggered by things that make no
sense to them all the time for no reason
like what happened like I saw some curly
fries you're like why what why curly
fries and then they start to tell you're
like oh cuz he beat you after jack in
the box and you're like yeah that's when
he lit me on fire that time you're just
like God why did these people why do
these people exist I know but then sweet
sweet people don't have children or you
know what I mean you're like guy you
need to have time I'm afraid to have
kids of course cuz you know what's at
stake cuz you know but like my of the
rest of everyone else in my fans and
families just having kids all over the
place not worried about a goddamn thing
that's how people that's exactly how I
they all make a force as much money as
neither just their pleather they're
flying out of them walking out of them
like a conga line don't care and in
there just not and they're like I
figured out I'm like what does that mean
I had never had such a less affair
attitude towards anything I always have
such a grave sense of responsibility
that that [__] may mean I think
that's ego you know that that saying in
the program I'm a piece of [__] the
world revolves around where you're like
you think you and I have this like no I
have to do it perfectly because the
world depends on it like there is that
maybe know for me it is because I'm the
adult child of an alcoholic so if we
don't take care of it the center of the
feeling is if I don't take care of it
nobody else will and I will die I will
literally [__] I will disappear and
die because I can't trust anybody oh I
yeah that the one prot the one of the
worst parts about death around you is
the consequence of everything becomes
death yeah my dog I think about it on
one of my dogs is temp a temperamental
little [__] when it comes to food and
today he didn't want to [__] use food
uh-oh and that's even a new food i
switched to 0 and so on my head I'm like
and this is the dog that cost me 10
grand this year oh my god it's just it
it infuriates me so much clearer love
him so much and I'm like I'm just trying
yeah I make you brown rice and then I
makes it like yeah I'm just trying to
take care of you dude just eat the
[__] thing you're a dog just eat the
food please do it for me yeah and it
just but because the consequence is
death of course I'm like he's gonna die
in my girls like he's definitely not
going to 100% like I won't let her walk
the dog because my fear is this if
something were to happen not even like
something was her fault but if something
accidental what happened in the dogs
died oh my god i would like judge her
forever so it's better to have a dog
walker to it and then something happens
i can just murder that dog walker right
unless we get your girl yeah and then it
doesn't affect my life right yeah every
time Ellis has a sniffle or maybe a
little raise temperature he's dying yeah
it's baby leukemia what he's dead I once
I hate it on Halloween I went to the
madrigals because there's where they
used to live in eagle rock there's like
a strip that's like every house gives
out candy so all these people show up to
do that strip on trick or treat so like
a thousand people show up it's actually
kind of it's fun yeah but like it was my
like like Al's wife was like you watch
Louisa so my job was to like stay close
to Louisa and you know watch her go
upstairs and get the canyon come back
down the tension I felt was so
incredible yeah I feel like I was in the
Secret Service yeah and and I was like
that was nerve-racking and I cookers
like oh is that what it's like all the
time she goes yeah yeah it's a tight
wire and especially when they're
newborns yeah Tom and I didn't even know
how to put Ellis in the car seat we had
to have a nurse come down and show us
and then the this thing can't talk it
can t it doesn't even it's not even
human yet you can't tell you why right
that's my frustration God the pets as
they can I can't talk my dog was ill and
it couldn't tell me what was wrong with
it what was wrong so much he's done so
much medication oh he's the best yeah
liver problem he's on plavix he takes
Viagra ones up the blood vessels in
their lungs he's not a thing called so
he is really is on viagra yeah he is by
your job no for dogs it opens up the
blood it's good for their like blood
flow some [__] yeah yeah plavix like
an old man
sildenafil so can I ask you one thing
remember you said in our last time we
talked about grief is that you said that
you hated it when the phone rang yes do
you still have and the reason you said
that is because you were afraid it was
going to be bad news that is how you
received the news of your father yeah
had gone missing so do you still have
that yeah I do yeah it's maybe a little
less cuz like my girlfriend calls me all
the time now and Dean Del Rey so now i
don't necessarily associate phone
ringing with death as much because i
have like just numerically the
probability i used to get so few phone
calls i see and now i will say that text
messages used to scare me also but now
i'm like in an emergency no one texts
that's true not a thing they do that's
true so those don't bug me out as much
or emails but the phone ringing I still
get like a I still get a jolt yeah if I
get too if I get three phone calls in a
row no matter what someone could go
saying like you see that it's like a
multiple yes I'm gonna call me be like
you want a contest and I'd be like great
if they called me again tell me I won
twice I'd be mad I'd be like we were
wrong like you're scaring but I will say
that you I think this living with the
girlfriend has really made you happier
because you seem a lot lighter than yeah
I guess I am that's someone else said
that to me too and I don't know that I
even notice it I know or realize it but
it but they were like your way happier
way happy Lizzie desert lizard said
she's like you see or she told that to
my girlfriend at the rappers like Kevin
so much happy so much happier you are
and I think it's part of being when
you're alone and you're with the dogs
it's like oh you know it's normal it's
natural I think you sometimes like
romanticize being alone but mostly it's
just because you know you're not hurting
anyone yeah and you're not like [__]
anything up yeah it's easier it's easier
people make it sound like it's harder
and I guess it can be but it's also way
easier when you have like all right yes
only yourself you don't have you can't
disappoint anyone your house isn't too
dirty for anyone
hired a cleaning lady just so by kroger
come over the first time we first
started dating cuz it was like a woman
could not see this [__] no I hope you
kept her the cleaning lady was she was
she has her own okay good you can't
trust my cleaning people know why I
don't know because I love steal no no no
just that she didn't think it was close
she has a different level of work she
well I suppose yeah women do Jenna um
yes there's no one to be accountable to
it's funny because I can't remember my
life before I had a kid because before
we have a kid is you're just the only
it's you and your dogs and your
significant other and like your needs
and your needs and then someone else
comes along and now I don't even
remember what it was like yeah before
where I was like what am I get it mmm
what am I can have for brunch would I
get it what am I gonna sleep in just
like eating standing up all the time
right someone else matters more more
than I do and there's some there's
relief and that for me because it does
take away a lot of the loneliness
because I was very lonely like even when
my husband go on the road that was just
me and the dogs yeah and yours and I
can't you know I go to the comedy store
but like you're even lonelier yeah I
know it's like but uh but it's it's kind
of a relief to have someone else to
worry about and and care for yeah I mean
I feel bad but it's a double-edged
sometimes I get scared of that yeah I do
I feel bad for anyone who's had to date
me post the death I mean I was not the
greatest before that but after it it you
there's a lot of breaking through [__]
yeah to like get to what is essentially
just normal relationship behavior right
isn't that you got a breakthrough like
just to get to normalcy with me you have
to break through some stuff well because
I don't know I don't know if you feel
this way but I think once you've gone
through and you and I both went through
kind of like wacky death like yeah your
father's death was tragic and my
mother's death was tragic like you and I
went through just [__] like what yeah
and I don't and when you don't meet
somebody that has been through it
exactly the way you have at least I
always feel like
there's always a part of me that's just
so other and that no one's gonna
understand yeah nobody's going to get
that it's going to be it's like our
burden like you walk around with this
thing that only I think I already felt
other anyways yes and then so this was
just like another leg up here that
you're weird like your where someone's
like your father pass for like a like
how did it happen they're like oh here
comes I'm about to get like whoa wow
that Wow like you just feel weird yeah
so that's why I'd like I don't like I
just don't like talking about it anymore
right because it's just like I want to
do that thing can't go there and people
that need to know know yeah and that's
kind of it yeah I don't know it's just
it's I guess it is different to a
certain degree but I i mentioned it to
my therapist I was like yeah I think
I've been like ignoring it yeah because
with like losing someone else I was like
I if I go there fully I can't like it's
gonna it's gonna like hold me up a
little right yeah for whatever it is I'm
trying to do where it's almost like I'll
wait till the seasons over yeah let me
get finished filming it's just a whole
job and it because they're real
consequences that stuff like actual
practical applications of being dealing
with grief or going through a tough time
like it's not just emotional it affects
your work it affects your relationship
it affects your ability to like get
normal stuff done and it can have a
ripple effect that sometimes I just
don't want yeah in my life yeah i agree
there are times i just like move through
it quicker yeah cuz i'm like i can't i
just i don't have it in me today to
think about her to think about it to
think about the the thing but then there
are other days where i'll watch like a
[__] episode of glee and something
reminds me of my mom and my story and
just more of a cry and then it'll pass
through me and then i'll go on with my
day you know yeah i think like a quick i
think i still have like those like quick
Alec are weeping everyone swells here
quick II think of real is like a quick
one in the car in the parking lot the
parking lot at Sony as it's really dark
right just you can have a quick one uses
like bits it's like yeah is like get it
out then it's it's like it's like I
don't know it helps but I think that's
what happens with grief is that when
something first happens it's like this
colossal overwhelming you spend the
first couple months in denial and then
you making too many jokes yeah I'll
everything's my head and then and then
you know you go through the stages and
then I don't know but I do find that it
just comes now in spurts or like I'll
just be sitting doing nothing and like a
wave of it will just come over me like I
won't even be thinking about my mom but
then there's like a black spot in my
brain that emotionally just like passes
over and then I get dark and I'm all
that's probably my mom it's weird it you
ramin I probably it probably comes to
mind in somewhere another like once a
minute I don't know oh you're you the
memory of something yeah just cuz it's
weird you mean you think of him that
frequently yeah probably oh and my
friend Brett like all the time what's
fresh though that that was a projection
that's probably why your dad yeah that
was that one like I at like I can i miss
Brett in a way that feels more active
now currently yeah you know cuz it's
it's just like newer and like things I
do because we used to work together so
when I'm working for other people i'm
just laying and I get to like show like
at the fact I don't get to like show it
to him to know it's done versus showing
it's like a different art director it's
not the like the same yeah cuz like he
was cooler I feel like better taste hey
I think he just said like was cooler so
like I'm like an this guy gets it but
like not I'm the same way yeah like you
know yeah we have like a shorthand so
like it's just sometimes like that but
then also one of his best friends who
was there basically like siblings
schiller want something like I really
miss him and she's like what do you do
what I was like I draw a lot feels like
he's kind of there because I oddly like
use his I try to use his standards in my
head as my standards for when I'm
working
so I'm like that would not be rad enough
he would make me do that again so it's
like so we were it's like that's the way
I like hanging out with him right you
yeah you're reminded of him through yeah
the same way i'm reminded of my dad if
I'm in like the forest right he's like
divorce or like when I play tennis with
Kirk Fox these play time I love that guy
yeah so I can't play tennis we plan and
we playing Griffith Park which is in the
forest it feels just like calm and kind
of nice and just like mellow like that
it's that's interesting so you take the
the met the positive memories the the
light things about him and it's like a
way to hang out with that yeah because
that's what the weird thing is a person
like stops existing on the earthly plane
that's what's like just weird I know
like you and me we're whole people with
lives yeah we've had amazing
conversations and then one day you'll
just be in an urn yeah you're not you're
fully not there anymore and that's art
that's weird yeah and so there's just
this thing that was there that then is
not you're like why can't I literally
can't hang out with Brett or my dad so
what do I do it's like you had a routine
so yeah you got to find a new routine
that's the most annoying part of life is
it doesn't necessarily get or easier you
just have to find all these new routines
I know like this sugar free ones as good
as a sugar one no it's not it's just
different I know I dread I just thought
about Tom dying oh my god like what man
we've been together for so long it's
just gonna wreck me yeah I don't damn it
all of them are I mean well as you get
older you don't you don't really hang
out with people that don't matter to you
anymore now so all the deaths are gonna
be [__] off gnarly but at the same time
I don't know if you experience this but
going through stuff like that there's
something not appealing about it but
it's so real there's something appealing
about how it gets rid of all the [__]
yeah mm-hmm it like it focuses your
perception and your experiences and what
you care about so
acutely that there's something really
amazing about to wear whatever it was
you were talking about with the person
when you find something like that like
[__] you were talking about is
erased in a way that's so efficient
you're like with a who kids to [__]
about that right now anything is cuz you
shouldn't have given a [__] about in the
first place yeah and that's what some
amazing about it I got my therapist to
kind of admit that there she's like yeah
it's so real yeah that you kind of I
think that's why some people who've been
through stuff we are when we see other
people going through we're almost like
drawn to them cuz a we know how to help
yeah we can like get in there we're not
afraid of it and that's the key is not
being afraid of the i will go stand in
the grief yeah whereas it's very
terrifying to a lot of people when they
see someone in extreme briefers like
yeah people that have gone through it we
just get no to like you just go stand
there mm-hmm go stand there and then the
if the person needs you they'll just
basically fall onto you and then you'll
try to feed him if they'll eat or
whatever or you just hold them while
they cry but you don't you know just to
go there like we go to the hospital or
like what room well I'll go we'll go
where's a lot of people maybe can't and
I don't really blame them necessarily I
understand it's their thing it's hard no
I've always said that the one benefit of
having had a wacky upbringing is that
I'm really good in crisis yeah I'm
really good when the [__] hits the fan I
don't panic if something's on fire like
I know I know how to [__] deal with
this I got through it like a Marine yeah
um so maybe that's the good part it's
just like but the inverse of that it's
like I can't go on vacation now there's
no such thing someone's like this is fun
right I'm like I don't know is it I
don't know I took I can't relax right
you know that everyone I know including
my girlfriend if they see me like okay I
bought a Dickey shirt online the other
day and they gave me a free hat and it's
I really like this hat like I was like
like I put on I was like oh should I
really like this hat and so I've been
wearing it you know and I like I wore
yesterday I didn't really need to and
she was like she's like what you enjoy
your new weird
and I was like a little like a frolic no
it's i put i put it like i got defensive
cuz like I don't want it's weird for me
to acknowledge that I like something or
that it's giving you pleasure and joy
because a i'm like i don't deserve this
joy of course not because you're
supposed to be serious all the time
because life is very serious and heavy
things can go at any minute because
things have gone bad yeah and it can
happen any time and you're aware and
that's the scary part of living is that
you go oh my god things can go really
funny but what I should do is like like
make a funny face be like kids many
fancy head right I was so stoked to get
free Dickies hat its camouflage cuz I'm
an idiot right but but then isn't the
converse of that of knowing the gravity
of everything and being able to be like
[__] it i love this hat I don't care yes
a day I'm gonna lie I'll my whole life I
love the small things yeah I'm all like
to me and I feel like I'm very lucky to
love the small thing yes it's the
they're the best I know stickers I know
I love stickers and glitter I love
anything shiny with her [__] yep glitter
is great stick i buy stickers all the
time yeah i have the dopest sticker
collection you guys like don't [__] with
it like you wish you good luck okay my
sticker collection is dope oh I own
several sweet ass hats I have a
respectable collection skateboard decks
like it's that cuz though I've I've
honed in on what makes me happy yeah
like in a pinch when I'm like oh I'm
feeling really bad I'm like you live
near the Norton Simon go to the norton
simon museum there's a Rubens painting
of a pope that is a banger cuz there's a
crazy silk thing he's wearing and he
[__] nailed the thing and you look at
your like that thing is Dell and like I
it's 12 bucks and I can go there and it
like brings me back to zero or like look
at my stickers or like a book on scape
ore like the little things are what
really playing tennis yeah tiny stuff
like that yeah and so I don't I don't
the big thing sameer like what the [__]
is at its tough even
yeah the big stuff is cool to get and
then you're like okay what's next like
it's almost if it doesn't ring with you
most of the big things that if you
looked at my life from an outsider
perspective you'd be like okay I see
like for big things mad right they
weren't they didn't do what you think
they were gonna do yeah not even they
weren't like disappointing necessarily
but I didn't get the feeling I would
thought I was gonna get no so I know
it's stickers never fail tickers are
great and I love Meekers hours and
sneakers yeah hours are great flowers
aren't I was at the park yesterday with
the kid and the husband and there's this
Rose day out of this Rose area of like
10 or 12 different rose bushes with
different colors and you're like how is
this possible so so beautiful I've been
thinking about lately I feel like
especially abstract painting it's just
human artist trying to compete with
nature or trying to trying to create
their own nature out of envy of what
nature does because that's what you get
if a really really really good abstract
piece of art if you stand close enough
to it it's similar to that feeling you
get when you're like in the middle of
the forest and you're like [__] nature
is a banger [__] crazy like if you go
to like Northern California those like
giant redwood you laughing this is
serious right and you kind of feel the
whole thing you feel the weird like
Disney circle of life yeah it's that you
can sometimes do that with art Richards
very rare but I think that's what humans
are trying to do with music and with art
and with comedy with all things artistic
right there trying to create they're
trying to recreate the feeling you get
from natural occurrences to a certain
degree right i think they call it the
sublime concert was it can't pump enough
over he's got ya aah yeah it's a it's
the sublime it's the touching the
elusive it's touching that whatever yeah
cereal existence never do it on purpose
no you it's my had an acting coach that
was like
you hit the tuning fork and usually it's
on accident you kind of put yourself in
the right area to do it and then it
happens and usually afterwards you
didn't know you did it but some was like
whoa right yeah that's what happens with
performing yeah the less you think about
it and you just do it's like something
works through you and the words come
perfectly yeah and you're not thinking
about your ego you're not thinking about
how funny I being or what's happening
right it's like you had those nights
where the words just come through you
it's not even you it's spooky and that's
the other timing of it you're like did I
do that do jokes ahead of yourself right
you're just like I and you know what
time you're like I'm going to cuz you're
like oh I have a joke coming after this
I'm gonna [__] you people up like you
hey like oh my god I'm gonna continue
crushing like you know it's weird yeah
you know what to say this whatever
ad-lib with the audience that's gonna
[__] oh wow yeah yeah but those mom I
had no sense that that was gonna be that
night no you don't know if that's gonna
come ever sometimes it's the nights you
feel the worst you feel on saturday i
had a good set and kirk was after me or
two after he was like that was really
good I was like I felt awful the whole
time right cuz they were like a little
cagey right so I felt like kind of Phi T
the whole time I hate that like I want
like I was worried I was gonna have to
get into it with someone so I felt
uncomfortable the whole time but managed
to still do okay yeah looks like I
didn't like it that's great that they
did I don't know well granted grief
gives you a really weird perspective
that's sometimes useful but also your
sometimes the bummer is yeah but I'll
tell you what it's good for and I think
this is what the Buddhists believe too
is that it meditation and the practice
of Buddhism whatever prepares you for
death the quieting of the mind is you
practice meditation prayer all that
stuff you're practicing for your own
death and so I think the more you become
at peace with the idea of death and the
feelings and like your keenly I mean
like dude we're no different than the
other animals that eat other animals in
the forest and nature
like we're just we just have
consciousness that's the shitty part
remember who I said salir David I was
like most of life it was not supposed to
be like this at all like this just
running around yelling at machines all
day and like having machines yell back
at you and all it this is not this is
the necklace but this is not out with
those be it's an experiment got a pinch
wrong mm-hmm but yeah it's weird the
only my girl I think my girlfriend asked
me if I was okay with that and I was
like yeah I've accepted it a long time
ago that it will be this and I didn't
mean like I was like I'll be kind of
relieved not like bring it but I'll be
like oh it's like it's happening now all
the stuff that I worry about will be
done yeah yeah and everyone will be fine
some people be said but it'll all be
done like all this kind of stuff all the
worry of whatever it hope that'll end
like all the stuff that we kind of like
spin our wheels about will end I find
that really a pillow so crazy do you are
you a John Lennon fan by any chance yeah
okay so i got really obsessed like his
band those losers um i came really
intrigued by the last five years of his
life with Yoko Ono and John had a
horrible mommy like I did right mommy
issues uh dad's gone like just shitty
childhood raised by grandmother I
believe and he meets Yoko Ono the hated
Yoko who really kind of is a POS if you
look at her enemies but they have Sean
didn't you ok didn't she by nikki
glaser's groceries groceries on time did
she I don't know if it's Nikki Glaser or
another comic but I know it's a female
comedian one who in New York was in line
at the grocery store and the checker and
them kind of knew each other because she
goes real time and she goes how does
comedy going she goes oh that's okay you
know it's I'm getting like I get up
playing but you know it's kind of hard
to like just have to make money and yo
corners like sweat just like to Qatar
car was like I got your groceries wow
that is like fully was like I know god
damn it now I'm a piece of [__] also
consider a level of hate that Yoko's had
to digest in her life and I know you
ruined the greatest band of all time
which she totally did
she didn't but she's well we'll get into
this layer something all the money from
Julian seems a little sketch did she do
that well that's what his complaint is
it like uh Sean and her get like it's
like 80 they get like eighty percent of
it and Julian gets basic very little in
comparison cuz he's from the first
marriage right she managed his estate
that she was doing full time with he so
the last five years of his life he
basically is a house husband that he
does and he stops he makes music a
little here and there but his existence
is centered around the wife and the baby
yeah and for him I believe it was a
really healing experience to kind of
have a child that he care i'm in julian
he had when he was really young so he
didn't take care of that he was off
becoming a beetle coming abelia but i
think his experience with yoko and the
Sun and becoming a family really healed
him and it's kind of like there's this
last interview that I listened to few
google it's like John Lennon's last
interview and he sounded so at peace
like he had found he had found a reason
a real purpose after the Beatles and he
was really content and then he gets
killed it was like and then he gets
[__] murdered by the douchebag but
but it was almost as if it was kind of
weird like he had come around and he had
do unit I don't know by said they said
similar stuff about my dad real they
were like he he was like my stepmom said
something to the effect she was like you
know he'd only recently started to seem
like an old man hmm she was like he
would be like you know when I Drive like
people huh click on the freeway like I
think use driving a lil too slow and it
was like she was like you know maybe he
was done with the world not like in a
cynical way right but even like me my
girl we're talking about that skater and
it was like yay he was only 28 but in
that short time he did live a pretty
beautiful life right and whatever ones
cuz I've been looking a lot of what
everyone's saying around there like he
was such a beautiful guy beautiful souls
too sweetheart he would he was it was
never like hey man what's up he's like
hey man how are you like how's your
family and by the way that's not a way
scarce my that he was just this
beautiful person
and maybe I don't know same thing with
Brett it was like he'd done a lot in his
life he touched a lot of people like his
memorial was his they had we had like an
art show of like all his careers work it
was [__] packed with like all these
amazing people like kind of like some
legit like famous people who were just
there because they were like this dude
was the [__] it was like he packed you
could make the case that he packed a
life's worth of of living into the time
you wish it could have kept going right
but in a weird way I mean the thing
Brett did for a living the thing I used
to kind of do for a living is
disappeared you know he was super once
he was like you know it sucks we're
super good at this and no one cares what
was it just being a graphic designer and
illustration like it's just not a thing
people pay for any more so the quality
has gone down it's hard to get people to
care and it sucks cuz there's like like
member good music videos oh yeah like
there's used to be all this amazing
stuff being made and now it's just not
really a thing anymore it's kind of a
shame yeah it sucks i missed that whole
experience yeah it was like so I don't
know maybe someone just is sort of done
I mean I feel kind of at peace with life
a lot of the time where I'm just like
things about right it's weird I have an
underlying sense that things will be
alright and I dad I know I got from my
mom because she used to say at all time
she was religious or she is religious so
that was her notion if she's like oh I
just brain ellentube ok but so I have I
have that as an odd sense from like it
may not be what we hope it is or what I
want but it will be ok like I was a
waiter once if I had to I'd be one again
right and like I'd sell my house and be
okay like it's a figure it could figure
it out it may not be like the the vision
board version of your life my whatever
that [__] is but like I feel kind of
mellow about things I try not to get
worked up about [__] well you're so
afraid of losing what you have that yeah
that's true because I've been everything
I've been poor I've had money I've been
yeah I've done it all yeah you just
figured out you do I've had have had to
where I was in college and I had enough
money every day too
for the plate of rice and beans in the
cafeteria is happy [__] that I've had at
some points lots of money and then I've
lost all that money and then slowly
gotten like a little bit back with only
losses again like it's just all you kind
of you kind of find the middle yeah
maybe it's just like it becomes like a
numbers game where you're like that if
that happened three times it'll happen a
fourth yeah and it does at all kind of
ebbs and flows and cycles and but I
think like an Eastern thought the idea
is that you burn off your karma right
like you do kind of become okay with
death meaning like life will suffering
does refine you it does refine your
being to where you do narrow it down to
like here's really what matters yeah why
wait a minute what am I worried about
again when it's just these things
there's a if you read this book the
untethered so uh the untethered saw
Michael singer I believe and yes it's
been featured on that Steve bro um it
was just recommended to me so good and
isn't there a no shot I love that about
uh how if you like went someplace else
all you would have is like the
essentials of what you are as a person
if no one knew anything about you like
if I went to a place where they didn't
know anything about me I would have
liked the four things about me that I'm
relatively smart mm-hmm i am not a
sociopath wait like I I'm willing to
help people and stuff I'm sort of funny
and I can draw mm-hmm like that would be
Who I am to that that would be all I am
to everybody and that's basically like
and everything else is this weird thing
you've created to torture yourself it
kind of like everything else is like
sort of false because that's not what
you essentially are what you essentially
are is what you'd be you'd be two people
that don't know all the other [__] yeah
like that I've been thinking about that
lately like oh like that's why I boil it
down to like what do you like like it's
like you like skateboard stickers you
like skateboard decks that hat looks
appealing mmm is that right simple it's
only it's hard it's
hard to like it's hard to explain that
to like a person you're dating yeah
because it does feel like I wonder if it
must be kind of a bummer to just be like
nothing that was really matter so it's
not like no matter what like where do
you want to eat but like does that
really even like her hair's right see
but here's the thing because I'm that
person and then my husband if I did
express that all the time would probably
want to murder me he's like we have to
pick a stroll matter ultimately yeah but
a lot kind of a lot right but the thing
is is I've learned to say that thing of
what is it [__] who care and then
simultaneously go well because it
doesn't matter now I am free to really
enjoy this moment yeah because it
doesn't matter life can be way more
enjoyable than I'm allowing it to be
right now and [__] it ok let's let go
and enjoy this time let's enjoy this
dinner and not [__] dwell on I think
it a lot it's allows me a little too
actually sort of begin a little to ask
for what I want because I realize it
doesn't matter so why don't
automatically go we'll just get whatever
you learn that too is that what's the
harm in asking or demanding rather what
you want yeah because of [__] who
cares this is my life and I want this
and suck it which when some if someone's
like where you want to eat you go
chillies we're not going to this like
okay but we almost did okay I'm like
what if they would have said yes but
like okay now that I know you want
garbage right let's find like a no
disrespect to chilis by the way I'm
doing a damn fine business over but like
let's that's fine okay so that you want
to have fun is amazing what you're
saying yeah so let's find a fun version
of something that won't like torture
your 40 year old body yeah yeah they're
just belief in like the self-help
movement I'm not sure I don't I never
understood fully but they're always like
well what do you want and if you're like
I want to be Tom Cruise I want to be the
most famous person alive [__] wolna
know what is it that you really want
under that do you want the feeling of
importance yeah yeah ok I want to feel
important well what else can you do that
makes you feel important well I guess I
could go volunteer down at the animal
shelter
or that and then you get the feeling of
that thing and that would serve but to
me that always kind of resume that's
kind of [__] because I still want
that other thing like I don't know yes
and I want the other things Steve Simone
who's constantly helping people 24 7 I
love him he helped me helped a couple
kids that are in a bad situation because
one of them these two brothers one of
them has terrible terrible spina bifida
like little dudes the cool like from the
waist up you wouldn't know there's
anything different about this kid but
he's they had to take I think take one
of his legs off and so his parents lives
are consumed wholly by trying to take
care of the brother and it's made it
incredibly hard on them obviously but
he's like the other brother loves
skateboarding I was like oh this I can
[__] handle right like oh yeah well
let me please like I was like dude
skateboarding I can get anything I like
I can get free decks and then I know my
friend has a sketch out like I so like
he basically helped me just basically go
over there like like Lacey's kids up
with a bunch of stuff that like they
think is cool which cost me a very
reasonable amount of money and not that
much effort and man I felt [__] I
wouldn't say great afterwards I wasn't
like you did a great thing but to say I
felt so even mm-hmm like I felt so like
like I was at zero yeah whatever bad
whatever was bad went away and I was
just like that worked yeah like that
worked that's the crazy part is that you
learn as you age and mature or whatever
it's all about it's not what you get and
I not sounds corny that's like the
Beatles lyric in the end it's the love
you make equal right to locate some [__]
like that the point is is that you do
learn that in the process of giving to
others and let in helping other people
with the [__] that may be [__] you up
like this show I thought I love it when
I meet people who like oh I emails you
this thing I mean I just met a guy when
i'm going to crime diamond oh my god I'm
crying we met we met in in Dallas
face-to-face and we emailed each other
back and forth and I read his email in
the show and we just wept like we hugged
each other and
I'd and that's the power of like the
internet besides jerking off to porn you
can actually make a living in other
people's lives yeah like share your
story emotional shorthand with people is
incredible yeah where you're like you
get this I get this and we're that's
what I mean some of the greatest moments
in like going to those al-anon meetings
is when you talk to someone else in the
program you don't chat yeah there's no
so small time address I mean it's it's
feeling case of it feels like small talk
you're hearing incredibly personal stuff
right away and you're just like oh yeah
totally and you're just like you're in
it right away I gotta go but like oh
it's amazing like I said like what you
were saying about it is I mean the last
thing of the 12 steps for a or Alan or
any of those programs is it's like
having had a spiritual awakening you can
go be service to others yeah the point
of the 12 steps and I think the point of
self-help and the point of therapy and
the point of all this [__] and the point
of dealing with grief isn't just cut
this constant looking at yourself and
trying to figure yourself out like
you're this super special gold plate of
Rubik's Cube it's getting your [__]
together so that then you can go out and
maybe be the cliff notes to someone else
is going through the same thing damn
dude that's what's up at me bro that's
it that's the whole point you just
[__] nailed it i mean when i was
writing that was the best part about
like an art lesson was i was young is my
art teacher be like oh you want to make
him look mad I'll put this line like in
this shape and I bike hola right where I
didn't know that and it would have taken
me months to figure dies like oh you
make it look like this and I was like
dude yeah and then when I used then I
started teaching the same place like
there was nothing better than showing a
fourteen-year-old kid how to draw like
the vein on Wolverine bicep to make it
look [__] sweet I'd be like now you
only draw one side and that acts as a
shadow they like oh okay they be so
fired up because they're like to just
now his arms look super sweet like yeah
dude they look killer not now you just
put this line above his eyebrow makes
them look real manda like oh I'm like
yeah do you look super sweet now I'm
like yeah it does hey it's that shortcut
it's giving people that that's the best
thing
due to view by any chance watch the Tony
Robbins documentary I'm not your guru in
that well bro you got no it's funny
though 18 teen girls in the background
of one shot oh yeah she's in she's in a
shot hello crying hello yeah well yeah
it's talking about but what I loved
about him is he talks about his story
and his stories horrendous of course his
childhood was a garbage dump and and he
just starts crying he's like I just want
to help other people suck I don't want
to see other people suffer the way I did
I want to alleviate their suffering and
you're like dude that's that's all like
you said that is the point of all I
don't want anyone to go through anything
I've gone right or when they are to
assist a loving support I told I knew
someone and her mom had just died and
she was making jokes cuz she's funny and
I was like yo I was like do me a favor
don't ignore it I go start earlier than
I did I don't wait I go go to therapy
like tomorrow I go I know you don't want
to but trust me don't it's not nothing
she's like I mean you know and I was
like no no I know it's big I fully know
what you're doing but it's don't treat
it like it's nothing otherwise you're
just it'll be years years and and also
years of sabotaging your own existence
sabotage everything forget it I tell
everybody on the show that emails me or
number one get into therapy in the one
get into therapy go Talon on you can
afford therapy go to a 12-step group
yeah do cuz it's not just I find it the
12 steps you can 12-step anything right
now it's not just about addiction no I
think it's kind of like everyone has
these problems since they say great
thing the means are like het didn't want
they they go one of the meetings they go
do you have problems with life you're in
the right place everyone's like yeah I
do i do I do but yeah that's free you
can go to group therapy like yeah words
that's cheaper my Tara's very expensive
but yeah go to you will find a lot I
mean if there's a lot there's a lot of
people out there looking to help because
then i think you get kind of addicted to
helping there's like oh oh this feels
good I gotta go to al-anon man or I used
to go to group there
be in high school Alice does it yeah I
gotta go al-anon Stoke cuz you'll hear
people say your exact story my god not
an alien yeah yeah I'm not an alien
that's what the first six months for me
was me being oh my god I'm not oh my god
you yeah you don't want anyone to touch
you too for real like that guy I'm like
you look you even dressed like me what
yeah you're not Annie feel so safe in
there well and the thing to again doing
this show is that i found that because
that was my thing I'm nailing and
there's nobody out there that's dealt
with this [__] the amount of people who
come up to me who email hey man I had
the same [__] grown up and just happened
and this that yes yes yes it is this to
further all the aliens to come together
and I think there's more of us than
there are of them the normal quote
normal quote whatever know anybody with
normal life I know if you super hell are
you know what I mean not tragic death
[__] so that's what I can say look if
you have a tragic her friend is it's
normal okay yeah yeah yeah anyway all
right I gotta wrap it up because I lose
my nanny here and if in a little bit but
I thank you so much Kevin you for having
me stay where can people find you you
can find me on Twitter at Kevin gee
Christy also an Instagram the same name
what's the G Gordon my middle name oh
look Gordon yeah very rare is it there's
Gordon Shumway do you know who that is
itself yeah how dare you there's b-roll
of Alf using the n-word that's very
upset seriously yeah like in between
takes he was being an [__] like the
guy was I think the guy who was the
voice is a bit of a drunk Oh is he a
little person to know he was just like a
puppeteer dude like off-camera and they
have they found b-roll of him dropping
in bombs instead of Alf and it's a real
bummer I think he got fired cuz he went
on the radio was like when he shouldnt
oven was like I'm the voice Alphans like
uh like he had that was part of his
contract oh to be anonymous I couldn't
say anything because the tune was so
good he's a [__] I remember that cartoon
i liked it i lived on to their on Mel
now Mac yeah melmac and he loves cats
you know cats yeah that was such a good
show it was think about the reality of
getting that [__] show on the air in
the 80s it was possible now now it's
like now
no no creativity whatsoever not about
it's about some people in their in their
30s they're just trying to figure it out
we all live in a lot for some [__]
reason except for masters of sex it's
which is a very interesting and
thought-provoking a good show shell ah
science & butts and butt [__] and
we're gonna see your butt so you see
what oh my god I can't be all right they
are knowledgeable orissa it was awful
okay it was awful no I love Lester so uh
sweet voice well thank you and give any
last thoughts for the bros out there who
appreciate you so much for coming back
um I honestly go like go talk to trees
man to tell the truth it sounds so dumb
but like wanna go go listen to the
forest yeah I like the the forest tells
the truth yeah no calories in the forest
no and no Lacroix Lacroix no there's no
hotter that [__] yeah listen here but
all right thank you Kevin thank you
yeah it's christina p aka miss Jean's
this ain't your mom's house it's a
different theme gotta be critically see
up at a cocktail party on dawn star
thinking John Locke or what's a Socrates
Aristotle Plato maybe Hippocrates got us
talking all properly topically just the
comedian discussing these philosophies
serious questions silly people what's
that that's teeth it is the ultimate
metaphorically and you know what that is
what as deep bro is deep bro